you know with so many new people moving
to the desert it's really important
to remind everyone the dangers of hot
cars and they get
really hot here in las vegas hector
mejia is live with tips for
not only drivers but for you if you walk
by a car
and you see a person or a pet that you
think may be in danger inside that car
hector give us the information hey there
sherry good morning you know things are
as you just mentioned
weather is heating up and we don't want
to see another tragedy and it only takes
a few minutes for
the inside of your car to become deadly
especially for children
so local firefighters tell us you should
never leave
children the elderly or your pets inside
of a vehicle
if the motor is running the car could be
stolen
if the motor is off the car can reach
deadly temperatures in just
five minutes officials also tell us if
you see a person or pet in a car
you are obligated by law to dial 9-1-1
you should stay on the scene and help
guide first responders to the vehicle
just consider a medical emergency in the
city of las vegas
police and will fire will respond lights
and sirens
to the incident because we need to get
there as quickly as possible
firefighter sherry also tell us it's
important to remember that a child's
body heats up
three to five times faster than an adult
does
and that just cracking a window is not
enough to avoid those deadly
temperatures so if you are traveling
with a little one or a pet
remember to look in the back seat before
you walk away and the vast majority of
cases involving children left in hot
cars
are accidental so if there's a change in
your routine
be extra alert and you can leave a few
reminders in the back seat like
leaving your cell phone your laptop bag
your purse or even your shoe
next to your child so you have something
to
remind you and you can look back and
look at your child before you walk away
sherry all right hector thanks so much
as so many people think oh i could never
leave my child
how do people do that but it does happen
people just get busy and
frazzled sometimes thank you hector all
good reminders